merci sophy merci beaucoup bien nous
voilà revenus donc sur cet autel où sera
célébré une grande messe demain nous
sommes sur la place masséna en compagnie
de marc vella longa et d'enrico macias
d'ailleurs enrico on peut il n'y a pas
beaucoup de critiques à faire sur cette
organisation parce que ça a l'air de se
passer très bien mais quand même quand
même il n'y aura que le rite catholique
qui sera célébrée demain or les pieds
noirs c'est une communauté qui n'est pas
simplement catholique c'est parce qu'on
m'avait dit au départ j'espère j'espère
que tous les cultes seront célébrés
parce que les pieds noirs c'est pas
seulement les catholiques c'est aussi
les musulmans et les is très vite et
j'espère que comme l'ambiance de la fête
le prouve
il y aura un oecuménisme est aussi une
communion vraiment parfaite entre entre
toutes les communautés qui font la
communauté marée noire alors enrico et
marquer ce que vous avez rencontré des
amis que vous n'aviez pas vu depuis très
longtemps
marthe ah oui moi j'ai rencontré des
camarades de classe
donc ça fait une trentaine d'années déjà
et etc c'est perturbant je dirais c'est
formidable et à la fois on a du mal à
réaliser d'abord de les retrouver de se
dire y'a il ya déjà trente ans on était
en classe ensemble
alors on parle du passé mais est-ce que
c'est forcément un retour au passé ce
qui n'est pas toujours le temps où
est-ce que vous évoquez l'avenir
bien sûr qu'on les phoques l'avenir week
de toute façon j'ai toujours moi
senti qu'il fallait se servir des leçons
du passé pour ce pour que ça serve
l'avenir bien sûr absolument
et moi je suis pas un passéiste
inconditionnels mais ma philosophie à
moi elle part du présent pour aller
d'abord vers le banc le passé pour aller
vers la ville alors est-ce que vous avez
quand même le sentiment de provenir
d'une même terre et de ne pas être tout
à fait comme chez vous alors que vous
êtes depuis très longtemps métropole ben
moi je dirais que c'est comme pour tout
on a des racines quelque part et il est
certain que même quand on trouve une
terre d'accueil
elle ne peut pas on peut pas la comparer
à celle qu'on a quitté parce que parce
que cela les parents il ya des gens
qu'on allait si vous additionnez les
gens les gens qui ne sont pas pieds
noirs qui comprennent notre problème et
quand nous on se retrouve quel que soit
le décor on est dans un autre pays et
notre pays
je crois que c'est ça c'est très bien
dire je vous propose que nous fassions
un petit retour en arrière à notre
manière avec pascal deschamps qui s'est
promenée dans les rues de nice qui est
elle au palais des expositions où il ya
toute une rétrospective sur les cent
trente trois ans de présence française
en algérie
et puis sur l'histoire de cette
communauté pied noir dans regardant ce
reportage
regardes tu te souviens c'était ça
l'algérie française
depuis hier ils sont plusieurs milliers
à voir défiler ici au palais des
expositions de nice
dix mille mètres carrés consacrés aux
cent trente deux ans de présence
française en algérie
une algérie d'epinal presqu'île des
alizés l'occasion pour ceux qui l'ont
vécu de revivre une page d'histoire
alors que les souvenirs événements
pénibles
tout ça
vous avez les deux des bons souvenirs
quand même
bons et des mauvais
on avait tous
bienvenue
nos habitudes on avait nos amis mais
les copains d'enfance d'écoles étaient
tous assez dispersées
surtout
ils ont les
c'est une façon ma tante seront trouvées
essayer de se retrouver j'y suis
retourné l'accueil est très chaleureux
mais appartient voyez vous on a pu
retrouver l'algérie 2
de 25 ans
de l'amertume mais pas ou peu d'esprit
de revanche les pieds-noirs safronov
s'est pas l'histoire
et quand la dernière génération de
rapatrier aura disparu leurs enfants se
souviendront ils encore de leurs racines
alors justement enrico vous êtes en
train de dire oui les enfants ils se
souviendront de leurs racines savoir
comme avec un nom mais vous n'avez qu'à
remarquez simplement l'histoire du
peuple juif et vous avez vous allez vous
apercevoir que depuis des millénaires
on dit toujours l'an prochain à
jérusalem est peut-être que dans 20 ans
dans cinq ans on en dix ans nos enfants
diront nos petits-enfants d'iran l'an
prochain à constantine où alger ou oran
et non non non non pas du tout pas du
tout pourquoi les arméniens quand ils
veulent retrouver leurs racines à
travers un pays c'est ce qui leur manque
nous les israéliens nous traite de
sionistes les juifs par exemple français
c'est pas du tout ça c'est à la
recherche des racines et les pieds noirs
les gens qui ne comprennent pas ça et
ben supporteront leur erreur parce que
si nous ont déplacé c'est aussi de leur
pote mardi la langue est ce que vos
enfants et vos petits enfants vous leur
voleur apprenez ce que vous viviez est
ce que voulaient les entretenez dans ce
culte de la terre écoutez moi
malheureusement je n'ai pas d'enfant ni
de petits enfants mais enfin j'ai
suffisamment dans ma famille justement
toutes ces jeunes générations qui
viennent
et même si quelquefois on ne leur en
parle pas forcément tout le temps et
tous les jours mais eux mêmes sont à la
quête de ça parce qu'ils veulent savoir
d'où viennent la maman qu'est ce qu'elle
faisait à son âge et ses terrains et
qu'est ce qui s'est passé et ils veulent
vraiment ça mais demain quand un petit
enfant dans mon petit enfant est plus
tard un père quand il aura les cheveux
frisés brun comme moi je tiens mais d'où
je viens pourquoi les loteries sont
blancs alors savoir non culture grâce à
notre identité
on ne perdra pas et vous savez il ya eu
quand même des grands écrivains comme
albert camus tafer il ya eu des grands
artistes de cinéma de chez nous je veux
même pas parler de moi il ya de marthe
villalonga répat si on fait sortir les
quelques lectures et elle se perpétuera
bien alors vous allez voir maintenant un
exemple qui va sans doute vous étonner
il s'agit de l'histoire d'un général qui
s'appelle le général mariage il parlait
comme vous un tricot avec l'accent du
pays avec l'ex en algérie et puis il vit
depuis de longues années au canada et il
a pris l'accent québécois revue complet
et c'était une famille de pieds noirs
qui s'est éparpillé dans le monde c'est
un portage de daniel leconte goût de la
peinture
et puis on a décidé d idées le pays de
mariage à belley
aller au bout il savait ya un certain
folklore des merguez dans la neige c'est
pas tout le monde qui peut mal à y avait
pas la neige mais y avait les merguez ce
jour-là fat couscous mais des brochettes
n'y avait pas le méchoui mais le vin
d'algérie tradition oblige les mariages
en famille comme il se doit pour des
pieds noirs mais des pieds-noirs pas
comme les autres écoutez plutôt l'accent
du petit square go et un mariage général
des forces armées canadiennes
et oui depuis trois ans maintenant fred
commande la milice de l'est une histoire
pas ordinaire qui commence par un refus
et finit par à l'adoption d'une deuxième
patrie
et vous
sport
et la france de nous donner vos
l'opportunité de réussir après
l'échéance à court terme je pense qu'un
croisement en france
yann hiérarchie cliquez ici si la
performance et le travail et les
résultats qui font que vous pouvez
réussir
vous voulez dire que c'est plus proche
de l'esprit pionnier piennois réussir
ici qu'en france je crois
réussir fred en fais le serment comme
darkman devant une manière en 65 de la
chance et surtout beaucoup de travail
débute comme cueillis dans la plus
grande orestiada on est toujours juste
pdg pour tout l'est du pays
si jeudi vous êtes à venir et vous en a
qui viennent vous me répondez et pour
cela il fallait passer par l'armée a mis
sorte de système de réserve depuis
quinze ans il consacre tout de suite
toute cette vacance et une grande partie
de ces soirées c'est le monde
intelligent tient aujourd'hui si british
d'emplois n'ayez crainte non à la
froideur et pas perdu ces arbres là bas
mariage s'ils sont qu'un style ses
passions d'être sérieux sans se prendre
au sérieux et surtout content contre
l'ami de la balle en plein coeur monde
malgré nos fins mer la pêche qui rend
faut plier les parcs de rire mur ici
aussi il existe mais c'est différent je
me suis à défendre mes amis pieds noirs
musulmans
la conversation est l'achat alors il
était le coup de fil l'algérie pu
freiner le jeu mais ça montre quand même
il n'y as pas pieds noirs à londres il
vient maintenant il pourra plus moi qui
voyage dans le monde entier je le
rencontre pour nous oui
alors cette organisation ce qui fait
station peut associer tous les pieds
noirs qu'ils viennent du monde entier
je suis à peu près 2000 personnes qui
sont attendues mais c'est quand même
aujourd'hui s'il disparaît sur de ma
prestation derrière ans politique donc
un non je crois qu'il faut juste surtout
pas d'arrière-pensée betty est avant
tout je voudrais pas que cette du
souvenir soit gâchée par une
récupération politique parce que nous en
tout ou partie d'une famille solide
quand ils sont peut-être de civilité du
père séance confrérie des pages de
l'histoire
nous sommes solidaires à 100% vous savez
que beaucoup d'hommes que je voulais
venir pour android y en a c'est assez
triste si c'est être un acteur tel que
ce sont représentés petit il ya donc il
nous aime bien il va qui veulent marquer
leur attachement à leurs pieds noirs
je trouve ils ont réduit le faire le
plus tôt déjà depuis 25 ans
mais si les réputations politique est
bien pour moi cette serait gâcher en
tout cas j'espère va très bien son
apparence et le vert pour le moment on
va jouer maintenant jacques auzou que
les fans connaissent bien ce qui motive
le porte parole des rats trier être le
président de tous le police dont on dit
faut ce qu'il venait d'écrire en
vacances qui est aussi encore le 13e
convoi d'une grande fresque veut des
lions à cette occasion montrer un autre
c'est celui des autres qui s'annulent
mémoire les pieds noirs sur olivier
orban qui était ivre
le nom de jacques rougerie chez robert
laffont monsieur santini qui pâtissent
palois est ce que vous êtes sept îles et
jacques rogge ses mémoires qui est
important dans des tic eu les colis
traverse entre pays est un peu long et
leur bourse emploiera tout faire pour ce
cadeau à part ça je laisse les français
les pires arbitres et les outils créés
je ne mêle pas ce que nous voulons ce à
m'élever le genre de compatriotes leur
faire rendre justice
maman pense au fise leur qui ory et à
tous ceux des noirs très âgées qui
traverse de croix y était c'est que veut
dire qu'il ya papillon 200 milles
rapatrié en france 5000 en france il n'y
aura pas pieds environ 7000 tr min alors
qu'en pensez vous méditation je mange
c'est une idée une idée géniale que noam
jean le trail point les gens nus sa
montre or c'est là qu'on vivienne autres
comme hôte et tous trois ont réuni
contenu et c'est histoire d'amour que
traversons de nous aujourd'hui kaki et
doit de soleil de son innombrable
claverie et cesser le journal qu'il faut
savoir garder alors vous ne pensez à ces
dernières can rico que ce soit c'est ce
bon c'est que peut-être un petit peu
quand vous dira peut-être peu archaïque
et ça ça me ça ne place pas un peu
l'espoir qu'on pourrait mettre de tes
pieds mais provoqué ce que je suis sur
mac pour les générations futures
exemples extraits nerfs ou notre
identité est vraiment brillant de mise
en valeur
il ya un grand merci aux genoux ainsi et
comme ancien tweed les applaudis par qui
nous entoure des mises a été réalisé
avec toutes les équipes de lâcher deux
ailes et perdrix préparé par isabelle
boulay est alors oui je vous invite
leurs suivis jusque dans leur ensemble
pour couler des pouvoirs et âme à 13
heures
la bise
à son départ
les attentions
les d'une autre une
elle sait qu'elle vient des prix paramé